das ist Bremen als schaschany
seit zehn Jahren erfolgreiche
Sportschützen und Mitglied im
katarischen Frauen Nationalteam
und das ist jasmians
ältere Schwester sie spielt sehr
erfolgreich und voller Leidenschaft Golf
im frauen-nationalteam von Katar
wir treffen die beiden unabhängig
voneinander sie stehen für eine
Generation von jungen Frauen die sogar
nicht reinpasst in das Bild das viele
von Frauen in Katar haben
eher untypisch auch dass die beiden in
ihrem Alter noch unverheiratet sind
Rehm ist 27 Jahre
29 die Golferinnen sieht keine besonders
schlechte Lage für Frauenrechte in Katar
i think we have ich denke Probleme mit
Frauenrechten haben wir in vielen
Ländern der Welt nicht nur in Katha wir
haben Gesetze zum Schutz der Frau aber
Männer brechen sie halt gerne weil sie
einfach stark sind
ihre Schwester reden ist in dieser Frage
etwas kritischer
bekam viele negative Kommentare als ich
mit dem Skisport anfing aber diese
Reaktionen haben mich motiviert allen zu
beweisen dass sie falsch liegen es war
harte Arbeit aber ich bin stolz auch
deswegen weil ich ihn nicht erlaubt habe
mich nieder zu machen
sehr geholfen habe ihr der Rückhalt
ihrer Eltern und der anderen Geschwister
sagt reden
und genau das antwortet auch ihre
Schwester Jasmin da sind sie sich einig
klar ist der diesjährige WM Gastgeber
Katha steht auch wegen der Verletzung
von Frauenrechten sehr in der Kritik so
gibt es das Gesetz der männlichen
Vormundschaft wonach Frauen etwa die
Erlaubnis ihres männlichen formels
brauchen um zu heiraten mit staatlichen
Stipendien im Ausland zu studieren oder
auch nur ins Ausland zu reisen
auch seiner Opa ist ein erfolgreiche
Frau die gebürtige Jemenitin den
Großbritannien groß geworden ist
arbeitet als Journalistin für das
Online-Portal Doha News
sie sagt dass ihr als Frau keine Steine
in den Weg gelegt wurden auch nicht als
sie vor zwei Jahren ein Kind bekommen
hat und im Vergleich zu anderen
arabischen Ländern sei die Lage für
Journalisten in Katar gut
wir haben zum Beispiel viele Berichte
gemacht über die Verletzung der
Gastarbeiter richte hier insgesamt immer
wieder Geschichten die den katarischen
Staat kritisieren könnten ich denke der
Staat akzeptiert das es gibt bestimmte
Sachen die man berücksichtigen muss aber
wir haben eine relative Freiheit als
Journalisten
welche rote Linien es genau gibt sagt
uns Hanau auch bei nicht mein Eindruck
ist ein bisschen Kritik ist erlaubt aber
nicht zu viel tatsächlich finden sich
bei Doha News einige kritische Berichte
über die schlechten Bedingungen für
ausländische Arbeiter indirekte Kritik
an der katarischen Regierung
Katar steht seit langem auch wegen der
Verletzung von gastarbeiterrechten und
zahlreichen Toten auf den WM Baustellen
am Pranger
ein großer Kritikpunkt bleibt bis heute
ein spezielles bürgschaftssystem für
ausländische Arbeiter das ist in einigen
arabischen Staaten und auch in Katha
gibt
nach dem sogenannten kavala-system ist
jeder ausländische Arbeiter verpflichtet
einen Einheimischen Bürgen zu haben das
kann eine Person oder eine Firma sein
und ohne Erlaubnis können diese Arbeiter
weder eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis
beantragen noch ihren Arbeitsplatz
wechseln
das kavallersystem wurde mittlerweile
etwas gelockt so braucht es beim
Arbeitsplatzwechsel offiziell keine
Erlaubnis mehr
in der Praxis sieht es oft anders aus
das erzählt uns auch so namaz Nepal er
hat Angst will nicht erkannt werden seit
acht Jahren arbeitet der 40-Jährige auf
Baustellen in Doha vor allem bei seinem
letzten Arbeitgeber hat er sehr
schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht
wie viele Monate mein Geld nicht
bekommen wir konnten schließlich noch
nicht mal Lebensmittel kaufen die
Zustände in unserer Unterkunft waren
sehr schlecht es gab kein Licht keine
Lüftung kein Wasser es war so heiß man
hat uns sehr respektlos behandelt
aber immerhin könnten Arbeitsweg Kranken
wie er sich mittlerweile offiziell beim
Arbeitsministerium beschweren und auch
klagen bis zum Urteil dauert es aber zu
lange und viele Arbeiter könnten sich
das Verfahren finanziell nicht leisten
Sohn am sagt dass es gut sei dass Kata
die WM austragen dürfen
was ich sagen will seit der Entscheidung
hat sich das Leben für uns Gastarbeiter
verändert das kavala-system die
Gesundheitsversorgung für uns ist etwas
besser geworden
es ist jetzt sehr wichtig dass die Welt
auch nach der WM auf katakuckt ich hoffe
dass ich das Leben für uns arbeite dann
noch mehr verbessertalschule
Sonam hat mittlerweile eine Arbeit mit
der zufrieden ist 2000 Euro verdient der
Monat für 10 Stunden täglich
insgesamt habe sich die Lage für
ausländische Arbeiter verbessert sagt
auch maxton von der international Leber
Organisation in Doha eine
Unterorganisation der Vereinten Nationen
hat es signifikante Fortschritte gegeben
in den Gesetzen und in der Praxis davon
profitieren hunderttausende ausländische
Arbeiter sie können nun das Land
verlassen ohne Erlaubnis des
Arbeitgebers z.B und noch wichtiger sie
können den Job wechseln ohne Erlaubnis
die international sagt dass es in der
Realität anders aussehe und
grundsätzlich seien die Bedingungen für
ausländische Arbeiter in Katar immer
noch sehr schlecht
wir dokumentieren weiterhin das
ArbeitsmigrantInnen ihre Löhne nicht
behalten nicht erhalten Monate zu spät
erhalten dass sie keinen freien Tag
nehmen können manchmal wochenlang
manchmal monatelang manchmal jahrelang
ohne Pause durcharbeiten dass ihn
Überstunden nicht bezahlt werden also
ihn werden wird eine ganze Reihe von
Rechten weiterhin Vorteilen
und da mal sind bereit sich mit mir zu
treffen wollen auch anonym bleiben die
Männer aus Bangladesch arbeiten als
Hotelangestellte in Doha der Jobwechsel
seit zwar nun ohne Erlaubnis möglich
aber das mach es in der Praxis nicht
besser
ging vor einiger Zeit zu meinem Chef der
auch beim Bürgel ist und sagt ihm dass
ich meinen Job wechseln will
wissen Sie einige Bögen sind gute
Menschen aber ich würde sagen 80% nicht
mein Chef sagte okay gib mir 1000 real
und dann kannst Du gehen wie sollte ich
das bezahlen ich habe nicht so viel Geld
so schauen wir da mal verdient 2000 real
im Monat umgerechnet rund 530 Euro für
ihren Platz in einem 8-Bett-Zimmer
zahlen Sie 550 real
dieses Handyvideo haben sie für uns
gedreht
sie teilen sich ihr Zimmer mit sechs
weiteren Arbeitern aus Indien und
Bangladesch
[Musik]
die beiden erzählen uns dass sie Ende
Oktober aus ihren Unterkünften geworfen
wurden ihr Chef hätte allen
ausländischen Arbeitern mitgeteilt dass
das eine Anweisung der Regierung sei
ich habe mich sehr schlecht gefühlt wo
sollten wir hingehen wie soll man so
schnell ein neues Zimmer finden ich war
leer das war furchtbar
sie haben gesagt wir hätten einen Tag
Zeit um unsere Zimmer zu verlassen
danach würden sie kommen und den Strom
und das Wasser abstellen
das haben sie einen Tag später dann auch
gemacht
wie soll man innerhalb eines Tages ein
neues Zimmer finden das ist der hart
[Musik]
mittlerweile haben die beiden eine neue
Bleibe außerhalb von Doha gefunden die
Fahrzeit zu ihrem Arbeitsplatz beträgt
nun zwei Stunden hin und zwei Stunden
zurück nach 10 Stunden Arbeit
das ist eines der Häuser in Doha das
mittlerweile leer steht weil die
Menschen die hier lebten rausgeworfen
wurden
sollen die Gastarbeiter wegen der WM aus
dem Stadtbild verschwinden
wir fragen noch einmal nach bei der
international Leber Organisation in Doha
sie wissen nichts von solchen Fällen und
äußere sich deswegen auch nicht teilt
sie uns schriftlich mit
auch die zuständige staatliche Stelle
lässt unsere Anfrage unbeantwortet
wir haben bei unseren Dreharbeiten in
Doha immer wieder die Angst vieler
Menschen gespürt sich regierungskritisch
zu äußern aber wenn wir nach der
Weltmeisterschaft im eigenen Land
gefragt haben dominierten Freude und
großer Stolz
[Musik]
wir genießen die Atmosphäre sehr die
gerade hier herrscht Katha wird der
beste Gastgeber sein den es jemals für
eine Fußballweltmeisterschaft gab sie
werden sehen es wird brillant
diese syrischen Frauen haben ihre
Ehemänner in Damaskus gelassen und sich
Karten für mehrere Spiele gekauft
auszutragen und wir halten natürlich zu
Katha sie haben uns Araber eine große
Chance gegeben
und wir freuen uns auch schon auf den
Asien Cup
das Cutter als WM Gastgeber im Vorfeld
so viel kritikeinstecken musste kann
keiner verstehen den die hier fragen
dass einige ein Problem damit haben dass
wir eine arabisches Land sind wir haben
unsere eigene Kultur einige suchen nur
Gründe um uns anzugreifen
[Musik]
rund 220 Milliarden Dollar diese
Gesamtkosten für die WM gibt Kata selbst
an darunter sind aber auch viele
nachhaltige Projekte wie die führerlose
Metro die Dora und die Umgebung und auch
alle WM-Stadien verbindet
das Kata so am Pranger steht kann Daniel
reiche von der Uni Dua nicht verstehen
seit der WM-Vergabe habe es positive
Veränderungen gegeben und der Vorwurf
des sportswashing sei unfair die glauben
dass ein Land Milliarden investiert nur
um von Menschenrechtsverletzung
abzulenken halte ich nicht für
überzeugend Cutter investiert in den
Sport aus einer Vielzahl von Gründen ist
dient der nationalen Entwicklung es
dient aus dem politischen Gründen Kater
ist ein kleines Land das von mächtigen
Nachbarn umgeben ist und durch diese
sportinvestition auch ein Stück weit zu
seiner nationalen Sicherheit beitragen
kann
mit dem Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit
rechtfertigt Cutter aber auch eine
rigoroseüberwachung der eigenen
Bevölkerung darunter leiden vor allem
auch queere Menschen die hier in großer
Angst leben im ZDF hatte gerade der
katarische wm-botschafter klar gemacht
was er von Homosexuellen hält für
ausländische Fans soll es aber angeblich
keine Konsequenzen geben vegetarische
Regierung hat jetzt noch einmal
versichert dass jeder Homosexuelle hier
willkommen sei und auch nicht
diskriminiert werden wenn es allerdings
um die Einheimischen geht um die
Menschen die hier leben dann muss man
sagen Homosexualität bleibt in katastr
strafbar und diesen Menschen drohen in
Kata nicht nur hohe Gefängnisstrafen
in Katar ist es verboten überhaupt eine
LGBT Person zu sein und darüber zu
sprechen Katar ist ein Überwachungsstaat
mit sehr modernen Überwachungsmethoden
das heißt wenn sich zum Beispiel Schwule
in WhatsApp Gruppen unterhalten dann
liest der Staat mit
und greift entsprechend durch das ist
passiert wir haben gerade einen Bericht
veröffentlicht noch im September haben
uns Leute berichtet sind LGBT Leute
festgenommen worden gefoltert worden
zusammengeschlagen worden
in Katar werden Menschenrechte nach wie
vor massiv verletzt es ist ein
Überwachungsstaat der seiner Bevölkerung
keine freien Wahlen erlaubt aber viele
haben mir als ausländischer Reporterin
auch erzählt dass es in den letzten
Jahren kleine Fortschritte gegeben habe
bei Frauen und Menschenrechten
[Musik]